Luke Cage is more than a power tool exfoliating Jessica Jones Love interest.
He has huge history of heroics and interesting fashion choices.
Also, he's getting his own show
So before you watch the show, find out, Who the heck is Luke Cage?
He started out as Carl Lucas on the rough streets of Harlem in the 70s.
He and his childhood friend, Willis Striker, were criminals.
Striker used knives, but Carl prefered his fists.
The two meet Reva Conners.
Both fell for her, but Striker ended up getting the girl.
The two subsequently break up because of a reeeeeeally bad date.
Striker blames Carl for the breakout and plants heroin in his house.
Classic over-reaction right?
Carl goes to prison and doesn't make friends with the inmates,
Reva dies in a car wreck caused by Striker,
Carl doesn’t make friends with the guards,
Striker adopts the name Diamondback and now “runs this town”,
Carl makes friends with Doctor Noah Burstien
who puts him in a “Biochemical Electrical Bath” made by Stark industries
which gives him Super-strength, Invulnerable skin and quick healing.
Luke Cage - I came out with abilities.
Carl uses these powers to escape the prison.
Once out he changes his name to Luke Cage, because he just got out of one.
Wanting revenge to Revas death
Luke does the logical thing and makes calling cards for a “Hero for Hire”
and starts messing with Diamondbacks business.
Oh and he goes to a constume shop and buys this sweet outfit.
He and Striker fight and Striker blows himself up with an exploding knife thing.
Luke then goes into business, Heroing for money.
Later, Luke starts going by Power Man because it is heroically marketable.
After a short time, Iron Fist joins Heroes for Hire
nd the two go on to beat up dudes with fantastic names like
Cockroach Hamilton,
Cornell Cottonmouth,
Mister Fish
And Freddy FireFace
I'm just kidding about the last one, but the rest are totally real.
For more on your favorite comics, TV and movies, check out gamespot universe.